foreign
good to see you
are you happy to live in a free state
wow
[Applause]
are you all gonna go out on November 8th
so we can keep it a free state
[Applause]
and will you help me once and for all
send a tired worn out old donkey back to
pasture
very low energy product tonight Governor
great to see you um but this energy
shows you and I think you and I agree on
this the Red Wave in 2022 starts in the
State of Florida we are going to launch
it
these polls coming out today I mentioned
partial now up by five yesterday was two
and a half now he's up by five oz now up
by three uh Carey Lake went from up by
five to now up by 11. you see now Blake
Masters is about to overtake markelli in
in the state of Arizona you see bolduck
is within a point of winning the senate
seat in the great state of New Hampshire
what's going on I think we're going to
win all those races and I think we'll
win many more because
because we have a situation where voters
are responding to a failed
Administration there's just no way to
sugarcoat it things have gotten worse
since Joe Biden was President the
inflation's at a 40-year high he's waged
war on American Energy he's bungled the
southern border like we've never seen
before so on issue after issue they're
failing the Democrats are still in
lockstep with him they will not break
with their extreme policies and our
candidates are offering a better Vision
so I think we need to work hard over
these next little less than two weeks
everybody needs to be going out to vote
but if we do our part and we get all
like-minded people and not just
Republicans we get Independents and some
Democrats if we all do that I think this
will be one of the best midterm
elections of our lifetime I hope you're
right
we know USA Today Suffolk poll came out
and the 16 of previously undecided
people they said almost all of them are
breaking last minute towards the GOP you
know here Joe Biden becomes president
and did you ever think things can get
this bad this fast 41-year high of
inflation record high gas prices wide
open borders abandoning energy
Independence all of these no Law and
Order no bail defund dismantled police
departments woke education versus
traditional education how did it go so
bad in 20 months so I don't know that
I've ever seen it this bad in our
country since I've been been around but
the thing that strikes me about this is
all those problems you said are created
and manufactured by Biden himself with
his bad policy you know there's
sometimes there's sometimes things
happen with the economy sometimes Energy
prices go up because the global Supply
he's Waging War on our own ability to
produce he's begging Maduro for energy
he's got going to the Saudis and begging
you know the Saudis they cut production
and people said oh they're doing
politics against Biden yeah I think they
probably are but he put himself in this
position by making our country
vulnerable to this what did you think
when the Saudis revealed that Joe Biden
was not only rejected his request that
they would increase production he was
told they would decrease it they said uh
he said okay can you wait to announce it
for a month until after the midterm now
if that was a guy with the last name
Trump or DeSantis wouldn't that be
called collusion well yeah I mean
literally he would have been impeached
if the Democrat standard would apply to
him I mean they impeached Donald Trump
based on a phone call to Ukraine about
Ukraine so uh obviously we know that the
phone call wasn't don't mismanage our
money that's what it was about and there
has been a lot of mismanagement that was
absolutely valid concern that he had how
are I lived in Southwest Florida as you
know for a while I'm on the East Coast
now and not full time but I'm coming I'm
moving
[Applause]
I'll tell you that but I but I Shawn
before because I've been bugging him
about doing this for years I'm like why
don't you come where your vote counts
but I do have to say New York we may
elect I think we will elect the
Republican Governor Lee zeldin and
you'll be helping them
it probably is the last chance
how many people are migrating do you
know every day do you have an average
because I I've read about 800. yeah I
mean people I think between 800 and 1100
we've led the country in net in
migration since covid by a country mile
we've had more adjusted gross income
move into this state since covid than
has ever moved into a state in our
country's history over a similar time
period and I know a lot of people will
ask hey if someone's coming from a a
deep blue state are they going to vote
the same way to bring those policies
here well here's the statistics when I
got elected governor close to 300 000
more registered Democrats in Florida
than Republicans that was four years ago
today we have 306 thousand more
registered Republicans
I was talking to the audience before you
came out to me
Ronald Reagan conservatism Works America
First conservatism Works Mega
conservatism works I don't like to call
myself a a conservative for no reason
but when you have lower taxes when you
believe in capitalism when you control
your borders when you're energy
independent you're the master of your
own destiny why did we ever abandon what
was working well I think also we have a
situation where the left has gone so off
their rocker that if you just show some
common sense you're going to get very
far with a lot of Voters I mean who
releases criminals back on the street
knowing they're going to commit more
crimes again what type of a prosecutor
John fetterman well yes what type of a
prosecutor would say yeah you can go
ahead and steal 900 worth of merchandise
just don't steal a thousand and we're
not going to ever prosecute you you see
a lot of these cities have really gone
into disrepute because of these really
bad policies so we're just doing basic
Common Sense tried and true American
principles one of the one of the most
talked about decisions you made
you you had 50 or 52 people that they
signed a consent form that they wanted
to go to Martha's Vineyard Martha's
Vineyard is a sanctuary Island
okay
kind enough to transport them to their
sanctuary
[Applause]
or sanctimonious leftists threw them off
the island in less than 24 hours I mean
and not only that they have a Social
Services office there that says you know
everybody is welcome refugees welcome
all this other stuff that's what they
were advertising they said but I think
what it showed is this the Elites in our
country they want to impose policies on
all of us but they do not want to have
to face the consequences of their own
policy and that's what that shows all
right Governor DeSantis who will be with
us for the Hour Return now to one of the
most powerful ads of the Year take a
look at this ad run by Governor
desantis's campaign I get asked all the
time who is Ron DeSantis well he's the
kid who grew up right here in Florida
working his tail off paying his own way
through school then volunteering to
serve in the Navy and deploying to Iraq
but if you want to know who Ron DeSantis
really is when I was diagnosed with
cancer and I was facing the battle for
my life
he was the dad who took care of my
children when I couldn't
he was there to pick me off of the
ground when I literally could not stand
[Applause]
all right let's give a warm Florida
Welcome to the first lady of Florida
Casey DeSantis is here with us tonight
there she is
here
well
100 cancer free 100 seconds are free
thanks to God
um I know so many people my mom had
stage four breast cancer my mom was a
prison guard she worked double shifts
her whole life so we could go to private
school
and she had stage four 19 lymph nodes
lost all her hair double mastectomy
chemo radiation it's it's scary when you
hear that word cancer isn't it it's
terrifying I'll tell you Sean that is
the first time that I saw that ad I have
not seen that ad since I shot it and
when I did it I asked everyone kindly to
leave the room because I wanted to look
into the camera and I wanted to tell
people exactly who Ron DeSantis is
because when I went through one of the
hardest things I've ever gone through in
my life I had a guy who was with me
every step of the way to literally pick
me up off of the ground and he wasn't
even just there for me he was there for
my kids and imagine as a mom of three
little babies when you can't take care
of your kids and put them to bed but you
got somebody like this helping you out
means the world
foreign
we're so glad you're well
um
politics is a rough and tumble business
you don't say I don't I do it's we call
it a blood sport you see the tough side
of it and then you see when you're
successful that you see the upside of it
it's how hard is it on you when you hear
him being attacked you know what I don't
even pay any attention to it because I
don't think people buy what the woke
corporate media is throwing at them
anymore I think they know the truth they
saw a guy in Rhonda Santos who stood up
for the rights of the people of this
state and stood up for freedom and they
are so proud of everything that you've
done and he was right through kovid and
a lot of the media who are wrong they've
never apologized for being Ron and so
wrong so I think they're proud of Ron
and I don't pay attention to anything
they say to be brutally honest with you
yeah and being out you've also both been
very active and involved I've lived in
Southwest Florida how is the hurricane
Sanibel Island was was destroyed well I
saw the coast of Fort Myers I I was
shocked I mean it was obviously a
devastating storm did a lot of damage
but I'll tell you the response has been
rapid we had search and rescue he won
the tropical storm winds were still
blowing in there helping all the folks
they did over I think 3 000 rescue
missions the quickest power restoration
that we've ever had in this State of
Florida for millions of people out but
you had those islands severed from the
mainland and so people came to me they
weren't State Bridges but they said
Governor can you help I'm like let's
help so we did one bridge to Pine Island
in three days we did uh
and then we did the Sanibel Causeway
which was severed in three places we did
that that opened to the public three
weeks from the day that the hurricane
came through the bridge I'm on a heart
break we got to take a break uh first
lady of Florida pleasure thank you for
being with us hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else